It's easy to enjoy Mykonos town with no planning, no tour and no guide.
This is a stop which lends itself to unstructured free time,...
...just lazing on the beach, wandering and browsing the shops.
It's the epitome of a Greek island town:...
...a busy breakwater, fine little beach and inviting lanes.
While tourism dominates the economy, Mykonos still has a traditional charm,...
...thickly layered with white stucco, blue trim and colorful bougainvillea.
Back lanes offer tranquility away from the cruise crowds.
As in many Greek island towns,...
...centuries ago, the windmills of Mykonos harnessed the steady wind,...
...grinding grain to feed its sailors.
Five mills still stand, perfectly positioned to catch the prevailing breeze.
A tidy embankment is so pretty, they call it "Little Venice."
Wealthy shipping merchants built this row of fine mansions...
...with brightly painted wooden balconies that seem to rise right out of the sea.
Today, these mansions have been refitted as restaurants and bars...
...for tourists enjoying fresh fish and romantic views.